بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي الحل الوحيد
لهذا الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني هو الحل
السياسي الحل دولتين اللي هو معروف ومقبول
من قبل المجتمع الدولي منذ
[موسيقى]
سنوات بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي الحل
الوحيد لهذا الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
هو الحل
السياسي الحل دولتين اللي هو معروف ومقبول
من قبل المجتمع الدولي منذ سنوات الان
طبعا نحن ندرك بان بالنسبه حولاء قد يبدا
هذا الكلام بعيدا على الحقيقه وحتى غير
منطقي نظرا ل طبعا ما يجري في غزه ولكن في
نفس الوقت سياتي اليوم بعد الحرب وعلينا
من الان مناقشه هذا اليوم ومناقشه مستقبل
غزه نحن نعتقد بان حل الدولتين هو الحل
الوحيد اي استراتيجيه عسكريه اي حل عسكري
كما قال جوزف بوريل المماثل على لشؤون
الخارجيه لن ينفع لن ينجح ابدا نحن نرى
كيف يتكرر هذا العنف باستمرار منذ سنوات
في هذه المنطقه وذلك لانه لا يوجد اي اثق
سياسي للاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين باتجاه
سلام مستدام فعلينا الاوروبيين
وشركاء بشراك كما شركائنا الدوليين
وشركائنا في هذه المنطقه مناقشه هذه ال
الحلول هذه الامور من الان كان هناك
اجتماع في برشلونه في شهر نوفمبر ضمن
الاتحاد المنالي المتوسط وطبعا برئاسه
جوسيب بوريل مع نديره الاردني حيث تم نقاش
هذه المواضيع وبدا نوعا ما نقاشا حول
احياء هذه العمليه السياسيه نحن نتحدث عن
العمليه السياسيه وعمليه السلام في الشرق
الاوسط و في الحقيقه لا يوجد ولا ميه ولا
سلام منذ سنوات وطبعا كما قال جوزف بوريل
الصراع الحالي في غزه هو حقيقه نتيجه
للفشل السياسي والاخلاقي للمجتمع الدولي
منذ سنوات
فبالتالي المطلوبه الان هو يعني اظهار
رؤيه
سياسيه اخرى او تختلف مما سبق لانه نريد
شيء اخر شيء اخر مبنيا على نفس المبادئ
والمبادئ هي هي معروفه لا نريد يعني لا
نريد حركه حماس في غزه هذا معروف بالنسبه
للاتحاد الاوروبي حركه حماس هي مصدر
لمعناه
الفلسطينيين الذي نريده هو السلطه
الفلسطينيه المجروه المجرو لترف الفلسطيني
وعلينا كوربين ان ندعم وان نقدم دعمنا
لهذه السلطه من خلال كلوات الذوات التي
لدينا في الاتحاد الاوروبي بالتالي هذه هي
النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه هي لا يمكن
ان يكون هناك احتلال عسكري لكتا غزه مره
اخرى نحن نرفض هذه الامكانيه لانه طبعا
كتاي غزه هي جس لا يتجس من السلطه من
الدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله او المستقبليه
وذلك مع القدس الشرقيه والضفه الغربيه
فهذه هي المكونات الاساسيه للدوله
الفلسطينيه المستقبليه وثالثا نرفض ايضا
تشهير الفلسطينيين خارج غزه لا يمكن ان
يحدث ذلك ونحن طبعا مبنيا على هذه المبادئ
الاساسيه علينا ان يعني نناقش مع شركائنا
مره اخرى كيفيه احياه هذه العمليه
اي نحن مستعدون لذلك بدا هذا الحوار في
برشلونه ونتمنى بان من خلال مناقشتنا
ومشاورات مع الطرف الاسرائيلي والطرف
الفلسطيني وشركائنا في
المنطقه سنساهم في هذه الجهود الاساسيه
قال جوسف بوريل في هذا الاجتماع في
برسلونه بان السلام يجب ان يكون اولويه
اساسيه لاي استراتيجيه باتجاه هذه
[موسيقى]
المنطقه